why would you confuse a child like
that's what I don't get because I just
think kids should be protected and I
think the schools are like brainwashing
the kids and they they want them like I
remember I found out my little sister my
little sister is like sixth grade and
this is at a Catholic school so that's a
little bit more conservative than a
regular school but even there they're
showing my sisters CNN why are you
showing my sister CNN in sixth grade
wait what
a sixth grader what does she need to
know but it's like CNN kids I'm like the
kids need to watch the news now what the
why on Earth do they need to know what's
going on in the world at 10 12 or
whenever you're in sixth grade I don't
know